[Musique]
elle donne quoi c'est l'entraîneur de
l'équipe nationale de basket pour les
déficients mentaux et cherche des
joueurs comme toi ah mais je suis
handicapé je suis nouvel éducateur avons
regardé quoi les gars y'a un mec qui
recrutent des joueurs pour faire une
équipe de quartier on voit pas car je
vous trouve handicapé et l'esprit
olympique où tu fais ce que tu veux
moi je dis pas sinon on va travailler
pour l'équipe nationale les déficients
mentaux
je vous en ai connu dépôt mardi il y
aura une prime pour chaque victoire sur
deux semaines une fédération des
handicapés
bah ouais enfin trois ans 1 m 75
sagittaire et mon nom c'est freddy
depuis tout petit je m'appelle comme ça
ça pose aucun problème toi tu veux pas
les aider c'est pour garin c'est
vraiment des nids sont vraiment cool
paraît effectivement ils sont cool alors
être crédible dans le village olympique
et lève les yeux au ciel et après tu
pars
oui parfait aux tab et stanislas a
essayé un rendez vous chez l'ophtalmo
qui était prévu messieurs qui vous
permet à autour de moi je travaille avec
la fédération dont je vais vous
accompagner pendant la compétition tu
joues à quel poste à nice le bonheur on
va quand même faire un petit examen
juste pour se rassurer
je crois que tu respectes ce que je dis
que je suis capitaine ouais c'est le
capitaine
je fais choper on va être les maîtres
les plus détestés de la planète
vas-y toi tu voulais t'expliquer parle
maintenant pas
freddy personne alors à te dire comment
tu vas tablier personne à droite
interdire de rouler une pelle et 9
on va faire tout ce qu'on peut pour toi
la ramener je te promets c'est pour
yoann offredo je veux la gagner cette
finale
donc on a vraiment fait une connerie
c'est pas grave les gars font la fête
ensemble
[Musique]
[ __ ] j'ai créé un monstre